bonjour
aujourd'hui on va
m du marquis de sade le marquis de sade
est un
vins français du xviiie siècle
1 le tiers de sa vie en détention
vingt-sept années au total pour des
raisons sur lesquelles nous reviendrons
c'est un écrivain pour le moins
controversé on dirait aujourd'hui
sulfureux
essentiellement connu pour son oeuvre
littéraire érotiques et pornographiques
et s'il peut paraître étonnant de parler
du marquis de sade sur une chaîne de
philosophie c'est parce que voilà un
auteur qui n'a pas donné son nom à un
mouvement philosophique
mais à une perversion psychologique le
sadisme
le sadisme correspondant au fait de
tirer du plaisir de la souffrance
d'autrui
saad a exalté la cruauté et la
perversité dans ses oeuvres
il a exalté la figure du bourreau sexuel
violent et criminel décrivant tour à
tour des scènes de viols de pédophilie
d'inceste et de meurtre et si beaucoup
trouveront inapproprié de ranger le
marquis de sade aux côtés de hegel de
spinoza et de platon le fait est que
nous avons ici affaire à quelqu'un qui a
érigé sa perversité en véritable système
philosophique
sade est tout le contraire d'un esprit
lourd c'est quelqu'un qui aime la pensée
qui aime le concept est qu il fait
savoir lors de son emprisonnement à la
bastille il se plaindra du fait qu'on
lui refuse l'accès aux confessions de
rousseau
un penseur qu'il apprécie
particulièrement
ce qui tend à montrer que si sa dette
est bel et bien un pervers sans foi ni
loi
c'était un pervers intelligent
peut-être même un pervers lucide
id sur lui même
choix existentiels
en dehors
ces symphonies macabre on trouve sessad
une véritable vision philosophique du
monde et surtout une cohérence dans sa
vision du monde qui doit nous inciter à
aller au delà de notre répulsion
première pour tenter de comprendre ce
qu'il ya derrière
holmes ce qu'on va faire dans cet
épisode c'est se demander quelle
conception philosophique peut conduire
un homme à la célébration de la
monstruosité
pour introduire cette incursion dans la
pensée sadien arrêtons nous un instant
sur le mot que je viens d'employés
monstruosité
et demandons nous si ce mot est
pertinent pour qualifier la pensée du
marquis de sade
dans le langage courant le mot aux
monstruosités peut s'entendre en deux
sens
la monstruosité physique et la
monstruosité moral
ce qu'on a
autrefois les monstres c'était des
personnes présentant des difformités
physique spectaculaire des difformités
telle qu'on ne les considérait pas comme
des êtres humains à part entière
c'est ce qui fait que les monstres
étaient essentiellement utilisé comme
phénomène de foire ou comme cobayes
scientifique
étymologiquement le monstre c'est celui
qu'on montre
qu'on montre en raison de sa différence
avec la normalité physique observable
le cas le plus connu étant celui de
joseph merrick dont l'histoire est
retracée dans le film de david lynch
elephant man
et lynch contre bien dans son film les
deux visages de la monstruosité
la monstruosité physique incarné par
elephant man
et la monstruosité moral de ceux qui ne
le reconnaissent pas comme un être
humain
en particulier son propriétaire qui le
bat quotidiennement
et le nomme son gagne pain c'est ce qui
nous conduit au deuxième sens de la
monstruosité la monstruosité moral
au sens moral on qualifie de monstre des
individus qui se livrent à des actes
particulièrement cruel
à des actes considérés comme inhumain
c'est à dire des actes qui nous exclut
moralement du champ de l'humanité
quand on qualifie de monstre un violeur
d'enfant
un assassin sanguinaire ou un chef
d'armée génocidaire
c'est au sens où on estime que de tels
actes outre passe toutes les limites je
pardonnable
les limites
du concevable
infligée
c'est un être humain sans défense
trouver une satisfaction psychologique
dans le fait d'infliger de tels sévices
c'est quelque chose qui pour nous est
incompatible avec les critères de
l'humanité
que des animaux fasse preuve de cruauté
que les prédateurs soient sans pitié
envers leurs proies
c'est quelque chose qui peut nous
choquer visuellement mais pas moralement
parce qu'on n'attend pas d'un animal
sauvage qu'il se comporte en être moral
en revanche qu'un être humain doté d'une
conscience morale se comporte en
prédateur
c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus
gênant pour nous
hélas
un élément essentiel de la monstruosité
à savoir que le monstre n'est pas un
être dénué d'humanité
c'est un être chez lequel cohabitent
humanité et inhumanité
le monstre c'est quelqu'un comme nous
c'est notre semblable
et c'est parce que c'est notre semblable
que son inhumanité perturbe nos schémas
de représentation
ce qui rend le monstre inhumain c'est
justement le fait qu'il soit humain
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui est à l'origine
de notre fascination pour les monstres
qu'ils soient physiques ou moraux la
dualité
la coprésence de l'humanité et de
l'inhumanité
la coprésence du même et de l'autre le
marquis de sade ne nous dérangerait pas
si le marquis de sade était un animal
le problème
le cas c'est un être humain et qui plus
m un an
qui justifie sa monstruosité
un autre main qui utilisent cette
faculté humaine qui est la raison pour
donner du sens à son inhumanité
et c'est en cela que le marquis de sade
fait problème à la pensée
le fait qu'il légitime par le biais de
ce qui nous rend hommes ce qui est
précisément censés l'exclure tuchan
l'humanité
c'est un paradoxe on peut pas à la fois
aller à l'encontre de tous les principes
de l'humanité elle revendique et à
travers des outils propres à l'humanité
donc la question qui se pose ici c'est
qu'est ce qui cloche chez le marquis de
sade
qu'est ce qui le différencie du commun
des individus moreau et qui rend sa
pensée incompatible avec les critères de
l'humanité
m quelle est la caractéristique humaines
fondamentales
qui fait défaut aux marquis de sade la
première réponse qui nous vient à
l'esprit
dire que ce qui fait défaut assad c'est
l'empathie l'empathie c'est à dire la
capacité à se mettre à la place de
l'autre
l'empathie qui constituent le fondement
psychologique de la coexistence entre
les individus
sans empathie nous
grillon dans une indifférence mutuelle
les uns envers les autres
quelqu'un pourrait être en train de se
noyer sous nos yeux ou être sur le point
de se faire renverser par une voiture
que cela n'ait veillerai aucun réflexe
de secours de notre part
l'empathie c'est le fait d'être sensible
au sort d'autrui
mécanismes d'interaction
disney interactions par lequel je
reconnais mon image dans l'autre
autrement dit par lequel j'accède dans
ma chair à la notion de communauté
humaine
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que le mot
salut en français désigne à la fois un
moyen de dire bonjour c'est à dire un
moyen d'entrer en interaction
mais aussi
le fait d'être sauvé
trouver le salut éternel c'est être
sauvées des flammes de l'enfer
donc dire salut à quelqu'un c'est lui
souhaiter d'être sauvé
ce qui veut dire qu'on entre en
interaction avec l'autre par une marque
de secours et d'empathie
ati serait donc une composante
essentielle de l'humanité ce que tend
d'ailleurs à confirmer les études menées
dans le champ des neurosciences qui
montre que l'empathie correspond d'abord
un mécanisme physiologique
l'empathie c'est d'abord une réaction du
cerveau
une réaction du cerveau face à une
situation dans laquelle on se projette
l'âge et la souffrance d'autrui être
sensible à la souffrance d'autrui
c'était finalement pas tant une affaire
de morale
qu'une affaire de neurones
nous sommes conformés nous sommes
cérébralement câblé pour faire preuve
d'empathie
à tel point qu'on pourrait se demander
si ce n'est pas ça la véritable origine
de la morale
l'empathie voir l'autre souffrir nous
renverrait à notre propre souffrance et
parce que cela nous est insupportable
nous avons converti ce sentiment dans
des concepts moraux
l'idée donc ce ne sont pas nos valeurs
morales qui nous rendent empathique mais
que c'est l'empathie qui façonnent et
détermine nos valeurs morales
c'est la raison pour laquelle certains
auteurs considèrent que la philosophie
morale de kant n'est pas tenable
parce qu'elles excluent le rôle de la
sensibilité dans nos jugements moraux
chez quand la morale est indépendante de
tout sentiment
elle est indépendante de tout pathos
une projection empathique de soi dans
l'autre elle est un fait de la raison
de la raison morale présente en tout
être humain et qui s'impose à nous sous
la forme d'une loi or ce que tend à
montrer une approche naturaliste de la
morale c'est qu'il y aurait un fondement
sensible pour ne pas dire sensoriel à
nos concepts moraux
et c'est parce que nous sommes unis par
cette aptitude commune à l'empathie
que nous regardons comme inhumain ce qui
ensemble dépourvu
fiera alors de monstrueux celui que la
souffrance d'autrui n'affecte pas
celui que la souffrance d'autrui laisse
indifférent
et alors là un problème se pose parce
que si on se penche rigoureusement sur
le cas du marquis de sade
at on réellement à faire un individu
dénué d'empathie
non aussi étrange
ça puisse paraître
non non parce que si l'absence
d'empathie se traduit par une
indifférence au sort d'autrui
force est de constater caussade n'est
pas du tout indifférent à la souffrance
de ses victimes
il n'y est pas indifférent puisque ça
lui plaît
ça lui plaît d'entraîner une mendiante
dans sa garçonnière pour l'attacher sur
son lit la faute et jusqu'au sang
faire couler de la cire brûlante dans
ces play avant de la [ __ ] et de la
fère déféqué sur un crucifix
ça lui plaît
ses sculptures
sa première incarcération
et donc si ça lui
lev et bien ça veut dire que sade
tout insensible à la souffrance d'autrui
il n'y est pas insensible puisque ça les
excite
[Musique]
excitation c'est le contraire de
l'insensibilité
ce qui caractérise le marquis de sade ce
n'est donc pas l'absence d'empathie
ce qui caractérise le marquis de sade
c'est l'absence de compassion
alors on pourra estimer que c'est pire
mais peu importe le fait est que si
l'empathie est bel et bien la
disposition humaine à comprendre ce que
ressent l'autre le marquis de sade n'en
est pas dépourvu
ce dont il est dépourvu c'est la
bienveillance
ayant ce qui lorsqu'elle se conjugue à
l'empathie produit la compassion
donc quand on réduit le sadisme à une
absence d'empathie
on commet une erreur
vision c'est se donner l'occasion de
comprendre que ce qu'au père le marquis
de sade
ce n'est pas une suppression de la
morale
mais une inversion de la morale
on a vu dans l'épisode sur nietzsche et
le nihilisme que nietzsche regarder avec
mépris
tous les systèmes de valeurs morales
qui traduit selon lui un défaut de
vitalité
les valeurs morales n'ont d'autre
fonction que d'étouffer dans le coeur
des hommes
cette force vitale primitifs qu'ils
appellent la volonté de puissance
qu'on puisse dire
c'est que la volonté de puissance ne
fait pas défaut assad
mais on commettrait une erreur si on
identifiait strictement la pensée de
sade à celle de nietzsche
k
chez nietzsche la volonté de puissance
n'est pas une volonté nécessairement
malveillantes
elle n'est pas une volonté
nécessairement destructrice
la volonté
sens c'est une volonté d'affirmation
affirmation du mouvement de la vie elle
même
la volonté
ans peut effectivement prendre la forme
de la prédation et de la violence
mais elle ne saurait s'y réduire
plus précisément ce n'est pas tant la
souffrance d'autrui qui recherchait par
la volonté de puissance que
l'affirmation d'elle-même
l'affirmation du vouloir vivre sous
toutes ses formes
sans considération des artifices
culturel que sont le bien et le mal
la souffrance n'est pour ainsi dire
qu'un dommage collatéral de la volonté
de puissance
quand l'oiseau 3 monge l'agneau il ne le
fait pas pour le plaisir de voir
souffrir l'agneau
il le fait pour le plaisir de s'en
nourrir
c'est pas la même chose
on entend pas
each prônait l'inversion des valeurs
mais c'est une mauvaise traduction
nietzsche ne prenait pas l' inversion
des valeurs
il prônait le renversement des valeurs
renversée ça signifie faire tomber
le terme le plus juste et en celui de
transvaluation la transvaluation
correspondant chez nietzsche au
dépassement des valeurs établies
alors que chez sade il y à un véritable
plaisir du mal
il ya une jouissance de la destruction
pour saad il ne s'agit pas d' annuler le
bien et le mal
il s'agit de remplacer le bien par le
mal
s'agit d'inverser le vice et la vertu de
célébrer tout ce que l'on condamne et de
détruire tout ce que l'on érige
en d'autres termes là où la volonté de
puissance nietzschéenne est une force
d'affirmations le sadisme est une force
de transgression
ce qui a d'ailleurs fait dire à certains
commentateurs quand cela ça de rester
profondément chrétien
un chrétien retourner un chrétien
inversée
mais un chrétien tout de même
se positionnant non pas en indépendance
met en confrontation aux valeurs du
christianisme
ils continuent de s'y référer
saad il ne s'agit pas de dépasser les
valeurs il ne s'agit pas de les
surpasser dans un mouvement dialectique
de suppression conservation
il s'agit d'ériger le vice en vertu et
la vertu en vis
on perd
cette démarche d' inversion des valeurs
jusque dans les titres de ses oeuvres
basé sur des antithèses
justine ou les malheurs de la vertu
juliette ou les prospérité du vice
un titre qui n'est pas sans rappeler la
fable des abeilles de mandeville
ce titre et les vices privés font la
vertu publique
à cette différence près que sade la
il s'en fiche complètement
sidéré les vices privés comme un moyen
détourné d'atteindre la vertu publique
c'est encore considérer la vertu comme
un but
pour s'inscrire dans un paradigme du
bien
or sade ne veut pas faire du mal un
instrument du bien
il va faire du mal le véritable bien
et encore ma formule est inexact parce
que dire que ça devait faire du mal le
véritable bien ça voudrait dire que
c'est lui qui décrète que le mal est un
bien
ça voudrait dire que c'est lui qui
institue le mal en bien
or justement pour sade il n'y a pas à
instituer le mal en bien
il y a à reconnaître que le mal est la
véritable nature de l'homme
que la cruauté et la véritable nature de
l'homme et que c'est pour cette raison
que le mal est en fait le bien
la vérité
homme n'est pas la bienveillance
la vérité de l'homme c'est la cruauté
la vérité l'homme c'est le vice et ce
faisant le vice on en est plus un
pourquoi appeler vis ce que la nature a
placé en nous pourquoi appeler crime ce
qui n'est que la concrétisation de notre
essence
voilà pourquoi
répudie le christianisme
parce que le christianisme condamne la
nature humaine
elle
le sceau du péché originel
faisant ainsi croire aux hommes qu'ils
devraient avoir honte et se sentir
coupables de ce qu'ils sont ce qui veut
bien dire
âge que sade et le christianisme sont
d'accord sur le fait que l'homme n'est
pas naturellement bon
car si l'homme était naturellement bon
il n'y aurait
pas besoin de corriger sa nature
pour sa 2 il n'y a
et notre nature
il y a à l'assumer assumer ce que nous
sommes
ir d être cruel
avide de destruction
je cite la crue
m bien loin d'être un vice et le premier
sentiment qu'un prime en nous la nature
l'enfant brise son hochet mort le téton
de sa nourrice étrangle son oiseau bien
avant que d'avoir l'âge de raison
la cruauté est empreinte dans les
animaux chez lesquelles les lois de la
nature se lisent bien plus énergiquement
que chez nous
elle est chez les sauvages bien plus
rapprocher de la nature que chez l'homme
civilisé
il serait donc absurde eux d'établir
qu'elle est une suite de la dépravation
ce système est faux je le répète la
cruauté et dans la nature
nous naissons tous avec une dose de
cruauté que la seule éducation modifie
l'éducation n'est pas dans la nature
elle lui ôtant aux effets sacré de la
nature que la culture nuit aux arbres
on part et dans vos verger l'arbre
abandonné au soin de la nature avec
celui que votre art soigne en le
contraignant et vous verrez lequel est
le plus beau vous éprouverez lequel vous
donnera de meilleurs fruits
la cruauté n'est autre chose que
l'énergie de l'homme que la civilisation
n'a point encore corrompue
elle est donc une vertu et non pas un
vice
on remarquera dans cette célébration par
sade de la cruauté
alors prépondérante ce qu'il accorde au
concept de nature et son rejet
corrélatif de toute altération de la
nature
la culture est une altération de la
éducation la morale les conventions
toutes ces choses qui conditionne notre
rapport au monde
sont des choses que nous avons créés
or pour sade c'est ça
s'ils ont du mal
l'alter
thür
le mal c'est considéré comme sacré ce
que nous avons créé et est considéré
comme indigne
ce qui nous a créés
la nature
le mal c'est notre orgueil l'orgueil
elle nous donnons de la valeur à ce qui
provient de nous
nos valeurs nos principes
nos lois
mais pas au ventre dont nous sommes
issus
vous l'aurez compris le sadisme est un
athéisme et c'est ça qui
dans la pensée sadien
et que le rejet par sade de toutes les
lois religieuses n'a d'égal que sa
dévotion aux lois de la nature
c'est peut-être là l'origine de son
admiration pour rousseau qui bien
qu'ayant une vision de la nature humaine
aux antipodes de celle de saad
considère néanmoins que l'état de nature
correspond à la vérité profonde de
l'être humain
pour rousseau l'homme est naturellement
innocent et c'est la société qui le
corrompt
pour saad l'homme est naturellement
cruel
et c'est la société qui le corrompt
dans les deux cas civilisé
rime avec falsification dans les deux
cas la corruption correspond au
processus par lequel l'homme renie son
essence
mal c'est la trahison de ce que nous
sommes
et donc l'inversion pas
de la hiérarchie entre le bien et le mal
doit être comprise comme
l'identification de la nature à la
vérité et de la civilisation au mensonge
inversez les valeurs c'est dire que plus
l'homme se civilise plus il se dénature
pour saad les monstres une
sont pas les gens comme l'i
les monstres ne sont pas ceux qui
veulent que l'être humain regarde sa
nature en face
et monstres ce sont ceux qui valorisent
sous le nom de civilisation ce qui est
en fait rien d'autre que mensonges et
hypocrisies
nous avons inventé la civilisation nous
avons inventé la morale le bien et le
mal et nous nous battons tous les jours
pour les maintenir debout parce que nous
savons nous que tout ça ne tient que sur
du sable
il n'y aurait pas besoin de lutter pour
le bien
si le bien était dans la nature nous
nous battons
contre les lois naturelles
avons même inventé dieu pour qu'il nous
aide dans cette tâche
car il fallait bien inventé dieu pour
nous donner foi
un combat perdu d'avancé
il fallait inventer dieu
autorisé à devenir
les maîtres
la nature je cite fruit de la fin
leurs dessins et de la faiblesse des
autres dieux cet abominable fantôme est
inutile au système de la terre
il y nuirait infailliblement puisque ses
volontés qui devrait être juste ne
pourrait jamais s'allier avec les
injustices essentiels aux lois de la
nature
qui devraient constamment vouloir le
bien et que la nature ne doit le désir
et qu'en compensation du mal qui sert à
ses lois qu'il faudrait qu'il agit
toujours et que la nature dans cette
action perpétuelle est une des lois ne
pourrait se trouver en concurrence et en
opposition perpétuel avec lui
que vois-je dans le dieu de ce culte
infâme si ce n'est pas un être
inconséquent et barbare créant
aujourd'hui un monde de la construction
duquel il s'en repent demain qui vois-je
qu'un être faibles qui ne peut jamais
faire prendre à l'homme
le pli qu'il voudrait cette créature
quoique émaner de lui le domine
elle peut l'offensé est méritée par là
des supplices éternelle
quels êtres faibles que ce dieu là
comment il a pu créer tout ce que nous
voyons il lui est impossible de former
un homme à sa guise
mais me répondrez vous à cela si luc
rethel
l'homme nu pas eu de mérite
quelle platitude et qu'elle nécessitait
at il que l'homme mérite de son dieu
en le formant tout à fait bon il
n'aurait jamais pu faire le mal et de ce
moment seul ouvrage était digne d'un
dieu
c'est un tel homme que de lui laisser un
choix
or dieu par sa prescience infinie savait
bien ce qui en résulteraient de ce
moment c'est donc à plaisir qu'il perd
la créature que lui même a formés
quelle horrible dieu que ce dieu là
quel monstre qu'elle scélérat plus
dignes de notre haine et notre
implacable vengeance
cependant peu content d'une aussi
sublime besogne il noie l'homme pour le
convertir
il le brûle et le maudit
rien de tout cela ne le change
c'est sur la
de son nom
il m'a dit m
ces dix films l'humanité nous portons
des vêtements pour cacher nos organes
reproducteurs
ces organes qui nous rappelle
que nous sommes des animaux
qui nous rappelle
tél
nous avons inventé la politesse
parce que la politesse
culpa dans nos veines
nous sommes devenus poli comme le
la police à pierre
pour penser son relief la culture
s'édifie
tu rends en lannion on exploite
la nature pour s'affranchir de ces
contraintes
ce faisant on s'en détournent on la
banque
john callen gratuit
u2 a prétendu
le
masque de cette ingratitude elles sont
le visage présentable de notre orgueil
ce que ça
oeuvre dans la valorisation de la vertu
et la condamnation du vice
c'est le refoulement de ce qui nous
constitue
accompagné de l'arrogance
ceux qui se croient détenteur d'une
vérité
là
mais pour lui que le costume pathétique
de l'orgueil et de la honte
la honte de notre essence l'orgueil de
notre bonne conscience
la vertu c'est ce par quoi nous tournons
contre les autres la répulsion que nous
nous inspirons à nous mêmes
croyant professé le bien
qu'on progresse toujours
qui nous fait défaut
si le sadisme est une inversion du bien
et du mal
c'est parce qu'il est une inversion du
masochisme auquel nous nous livrons à
chaque fois que nous condamnons ce que
la nature a fait de nous
sadler
une vertu reposant sur le refoulement
anxieux de notre nature
il ne croit pas dans une vertu que la
mort
rend dérisoires
la vertu le vis tous ce compte
fond dans le cercueil je cite la vertu
n'est
heures dont le culte ne consiste qu'à
des immolations perpétuel à des révoltes
sans nombre contre les inspirations du
tempérament
de tels mouvements peuvent ils être
naturel la nature conseils tels ceux qui
l' autre âge
voit pas la dupe génie de ces femmes que
tu entends nommé vertueuse
ce ne sont pas les mêmes passions que
nous qu'elle serve mais elles en ont
d'autres est souvent bien plus
méprisable
c'est l'ambition c'est l'orgueil
des intérêts particuliers souvent encore
la froideur seul d'un tempérament qui ne
leurs conseils rien
nous quelque chose à de pareilles êtres
non
a suivi les uniques impression de
l'amour de soi
est il donc meilleure plus sage plus à
propos
sacrifier à l'égoïsme compassion
pour moi je crois que l'un vaut bien
l'autre
qui n'écoutent que cette dernière voie à
bien plus de raisons sans doute
puisque lé seul l'organe de la nature
tandis que l'autre n'est que celle de la
sottise et du préjugé
gut de [ __ ] éjaculer de ce membre
génie mais plus précieuse que les actes
les plus sublimes d'une vertu que je
méprise
dans crime
le personnage de raskolnikov est
convaincu que l'humanité se divise en
deux catégories
les gens ordinaires dont la vie n'a pas
de valeur
et les gens extraordinaires
heures d'un droit moral de tuer il dit
or de mettre ses actes en conformité
avec sa pensée
sid d'assassiner aliona ivanovna une
vieille près d'eux sur gage que
raskolnikov estime inutile sur terre
il met son projet à exécution
rions appartenir à la catégorie des gens
extraordinaires
finalement raskolnikov se retrouve
confronté à sa culpabilité lui
c'est que la vie de l'usure hier
n'avaient aucune valeur
le voilà pris de remords incapable de
faire taire sa conscience morale
peut-être raskolnikov était-il encore
sous le joug de la morale collective et
2 sont interdits du meurtre
peut-être était-il encore
ce qu'ils ne le croyaient influencé par
les conventions culturelles qui prohibe
la destruction de la vie d'autrui
il était pourtant sûr de lui peut-être
naître
râler les lois
interdisait en fait d'accomplir ce que
sa conscience l'empêcher déjà
d'accomplir
peut-être n'at-il pas vu que sa
conscience ne s'opposait pas à sa nature
mais quel en était le fruit
et qu'elle l'a prolongé en lui donnant
une forme
la conscience
et la forme de notes
tueur et tout ce que la conscience créer
tout ce qu'elle érige
et à quoi elle donne du sens fait aussi
partie de notre nature
car si l'année
or et où tout ce que nous faisons disons
nous croyons provient
thür y compris ce que nous faisons
pour la changer y compris ce que nous
disons pour la contester et comprime ce
que nous
on pour l'oublier je vous remercie
[Musique]